welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Cecile Fremont who is an associate
professor of African and South Atlantic
art in the history of art department at
Yale her writing and teaching focus on
the visual material and religious
culture of Africa and Latin America with
a special emphasis on the early modern
period and on the Portuguese speaking
Atlantic world her first book the art of
conversion Christian visual culture in
the kingdom of Kongo when a number of
awards and her essays on African and
Latin American art have appeared in a
number of publications including
colonial Latin American review and
African arts today we'll talk with
professor Fremont about the circulation
of African visual material and religious
culture in the context of the slave
trade within the early modern atlantic
world
welcome professor Fermont thank you for
having me let's start with an overview
of your work tell us about it
yes thank you well I'm actually at a
very exciting point in the arch of
research because I'm finishing two big
project and just starting on a new
exciting one the projects that I'm
finishing the one deals with images that
missionaries that went to Congo and
Angola in the 17th and 18th century
created as literally practical guides to
the mission for future missionaries and
they're interesting because they're
European images made by Europeans for
Europeans but I'm arguing that in fact
they are co-productions
between the local African populations
and the missionaries and so they should
be read as both African images and
European images the second project is
looking at pouches and packets that were
masterminded by people of African birth
or descent in the early modern Atlantic
world that gave their
wearer's protection against
vulnerability and so they are understood
as amulets or as different types of
empowered packets and there are ways in
which the makers were able to bring
scraps of european esoteric and
religious material and transform them
into objects of action and protection
for Africans but also Europeans Wow and
as I'm thinking about this to project I
[Music]
encountered these new questions about
what I think of as the material
histories of the slave trade thinking
about those objects and was images and
the ways in which they participated in
creating the early modern world in the
context of the rise and the apogee
really of the slave trade era so that
new project is looking at the 18th
century and looking at the exchange of
objects between European merchants and
African rulers on the Atlantic coast but
these objects are actually exquisite
pieces that are made in Europe for
particular rulers now particular
merchants on the Atlantic coast as a way
to create diplomatic and commercial
relationships between the Europeans and
the African merchants and what's
striking about these objects is they go
against that perception that the slave
trade was an inacol exchange between
European merchants that were bringing
trifles things of little price and
little sophistication to the Atlantic
coast and in exchange would obtain
objects and merchandise of great value
in in particular and slave men and women
but looking at these objects that are so
fine they're bespoke they're made to the
specifications of the African rulers we
start to see of
very different type of exchange that is
based on a very fine-grain engagement at
the level of aesthetic and design
between the two parties okay well that
sounds like really fascinating work for
you how did you become interested in it
yes thank you well you know as an art
historian I spend a lot of time looking
at written documents in archives but I
also spend a lot of time in museums
looking at objects and really gaining a
better understanding of the material and
visual culture of the Atlantic world and
I was in a museum in the west of France
that is focusing on Frances connection
with the Atlantic world and I saw that
object that was really a lightning bolt
for me and it was a silver knife or
sword about this big that on the one
hand I had fine decorations and silver
smithing that is really typical of late
18th century French metalworking Rococo
flowers and embellishments but on the
other hand at the really typical shape
of sympathy which is a type of
ceremonial knife that was used in West
Central Africa around the mouth of the
Congo River so by the shape for me it
was clear that it was that type of
objects that I knew on the African
context could be made of metal sometimes
they're made of wood but in this case it
was silver and on it was written
dedication to a particular person and
the ratio Kuta who is an historical
figure who lived in the second half of
the 18th century on the coast of the
congo and this object there that was so
fine was made for that person and it was
such so dedicated to him precisely but
it literally had the name of that
African ruler
on it and I remembered having read about
that knife before through a short piece
of the conservator of the museum
handmade but seeing it in person was
just a revelation in understanding the
paradoxes that went into its making that
on the one hand it was an object I was
made to impress it was silver it's shiny
it's decorated but on the other hand you
could see that there was attempts at
saving some of the expense of making it
that the blade was so thin that it it
could hardly stand understand but it was
you know that's that piece that was
really baffling and so I started
wondering so what are the types of
relationship that are involved in the
making of that object and what is that
object in terms of innovation and in
terms of the kinds of reckonings that
the artists and the metal workers in
France had to go through to create that
piece that after all was a French made
piece that was made after a African
template of knife that was sent to an
African ruler to impress him with the
riches of France so there was an
entanglement of aesthetic decisions
design practices and it really kind of
challenged our understanding of that
exchange of what merchants of from
Europe brought to the Atlantic coast in
this case they had thought long and hard
into what kind of objects they had to
bring and that really started me
thinking about that exchange and really
the possibilities that finding objects
like this and studying them could open
up in terms of understanding the early
modern world better okay so let's talk
about your methodology and how you did
the research so it must have been
interesting for
to try and track how the knife came to
be so do you know who commissioned the
knife for the African ruler tell us a
bit about what you learned yes
well I'm at the beginning of that
research in a way so there is a lot that
we know because we have the name of the
African ruler who was a person in charge
in that particular region of dealing
with European merchants so European
merchants needed
he's agreement to be able to trade in
that region and there was a tremendous
competitions between different places so
the French merchants were in competition
against the Portuguese merchants in
competition against the the Dutch
merchants and and the race was the one
who was deciding who could trade at what
price and in what quantities so they
really needed to the to have his
agreement okay let me ask you trading so
they were slaving trades but they were
trading slaves as well as other goods
yes yes they were trading slaves as well
as over goods but principally the core
of the exchange and that in that region
and at that moment of the late 18th
century was really the trading enslaved
men and women that was that the main
part of the story
oh Claire alright so continue where I
interrupted you yes so they needed to
interest to impress and race will have
this kind of gift and so I went back and
I'm starting to go back more as
systematically to the records that the
slave traders were keeping about their
activities and these records were
painstaking because the six economically
were so high and it involved all the
mechanisms of what we think as a modern
international trade it involves
insurance it involved record-keeping
double ledger accounting and so
we have this wealth of information that
has been worked on really to great
results by economic historians but in a
way that was more geared at
understanding the macroeconomic picture
of the development of Europe and Africa
at one level and at micro economic level
thinking about a balance of the Train
who profited and to an extent but going
back to these documents as an art
historian I'm interested in the
particularities of the objects that they
are trading there when they are
describing the type of cloth they are
bringing to the African cloud to the
African cost they are describing exactly
what type of cloth what designs for what
region is needed and then they're
describing some of those exceptional
objects such as the chimp at a knife
that I was discussing and so going back
to these records you can flesh out a
much more fine-grained history of the
material exchange that went on on the
African coast okay so let's talk about
how the exchange influenced you know the
art and aesthetic of both places what
have you found
yes on the one hand it is really
intriguing to think about the ways in
which artisans and artists in Europe
were making objects for an african
public and we tend to think of the
exchange in the other direction
that Europeans are collectors and
connoisseurs and interested in exotic
objects but by these records we know
that this was true in the other
direction that African rulers were
collectors and connoisseurs and really
excited about exotic objects and so it's
fleshing out that
that process and it's a process that
really goes back to the first moment of
the making of the Atlantic trade in
slaves we have very exciting documents
from the early 16th century that
described the first encounters the first
decades of encounters I should say
between Portugal and the kingdom of
Kongo for example in which the king of
Portugal is sending a panel paintings
metal works the finest kinds of objects
that it would be sending to other rulers
all around the world to impress his
interlocutor in the Congo and the king
of Congo is receiving them with great
interest and is asking for more because
it's interested about this newfangled
artworks and objects and on the other
hand the king of Congo is sending the
incredibly fine textile that is artisans
are making and these objects are also
received with great enthusiasm at the
court of Portugal so it's really an
exchange that goes both ways and this is
happening in the first decade of the
sixteenth century in a way that we can
approximate to diplomatic exchange
elsewhere in the world but just one step
after discussing this exchange in the
Portuguese document you have the more
sinister side that is embedded in which
the king of Portugal is giving direction
to his diplomats of oh give this great
gift to my brother the king of Congo and
then remember to tell him that I sent
this gift at great cost and so he should
make sure that those ships are full of
merchandise in return
and this merchandise is slaves slaves
slaves it repeats in the instructions
get slaves and so that's the history
that we are following but I am following
over centuries and it changes to some
extent in the quantity in
the number of enslavement and women that
are being traded but the nature of the
objects that are going back and forth as
a consequence remain a full range up to
the very most fine objects that are
being made in Europe and so I'm
interested in in following that right I
mean it is fascinating to hear you speak
of this because I think many people it's
virtually unknown that the African
leaders were complicit in sending their
you know brothers and sisters off to
different lands to be slaves I don't I'm
not necessarily sure that people are
really aware of that so I think that's
very interesting and and that it was a
one-way trade in reality because you
know while both coasts were trading
these you know bespoke artistic objects
the slaves are only really going in one
way so I find that fascinating yeah you
know I'm not sure how in a way how
important it is to think of it in terms
of being complicit what we really need
to get our head around is that it was a
trade that was complex and sophisticated
and that involved two set of people
whose goals whose motivations were
equally complex and equally
sophisticated and I think it's much more
important to flesh out the story in this
way okay or it's equally important to
flesh out the story in this way to
understand that the two parties involved
were of were equally human in a way in
in their in their motivations in their
goals and in the means that they were
using to achieve prosperity which was
the goal in both side and it took
different forms and really what I want
to achieve with that project
is to have a better understanding of the
ways in which Africa and Africans
participated as full actors in the
crafting of the Atlantic world and in
some of the most important aspect of the
creation of the modern world of
modernity that we understand so far as a
European story a story that in which non
Europeans are serving as foils to the
construction of the European modern
subject right that is not a savage for
example right that is rational versus
irrational and looking at the terms of
exchange and looking at the
sophistication of African interlocutors
we can understand better the formation
of that modernity in that the Africans
participated in it they were not
irrational they didn't want they didn't
not understand the value of objects they
actually were parts of determining what
value was sure and what sophistication
was and what shape it took and fleshing
out that story really helps us
understand our world much better yes I
mean it and it is a it is a fascinating
I think a way to think about it actually
so I'm curious to know were there any
surprises that you did not anticipate as
you're doing your research did you come
across anything that you said Wow
yes so there was that that object but
also when you look at the record and I
knew the slips reading record existed
but I hadn't spend extensive time with
them and as I'm starting to delve into
them it's just mind-boggling
how precise they are and how much there
was an engagement on the part of the
slave traders we find details of
aesthetic values on the part of their
interlocutors so we can
actually go back to the 16th century to
some extent but much more the 17th and
the 18th century and have really fine
grain descriptions of the preferences of
African rulers elite in particular on
different points of the African
continent on the Atlantic side can you
tell us about some of them
I have general examples but one of them
would be the really exciting reception
that a blue checkered cloth received in
Central Africa which is a very kind of
modest type of of cloth that is
literally a cotton and with blue check
net and it was received in Central
African Congo and Angola as this objects
that then was integrated into the
regalia of the rulers so that you see
images that were made of African rulers
at the time in west central Africa and
they are wearing their very prestigious
cap of status chains of gold really
fancy things and this blue check cloth
that really becomes part of their
regalia and becomes a way of heralding
their power and their legitimacy and
probably my practices is that part of it
has to do with showcasing their the
reach of their power right or the
ability to reach harness and mobilize
long distance trade network and make it
part of the reasons why their legitimate
rulers and then this cloth continues to
be used for centuries and ends up being
used in those power object that we
imagine sometimes as a typical of the
African continent so figures in human
forms that
are empowered activated with nails and
other shards of metal and these shards
of metal sometimes are tied with this
blue and white check and so in their
that texture continues to talk about
power and sophistication for centuries
and what's interesting is that these
objects are really the emblem of wrong
ideas about the heart of darkness right
Africa is untouched and having this
ancestral historical practices but these
objects are actually eminently
historical and that they were created at
the moment of the height of the slave
trade and through objects that are being
traded that arrived on the continent
with the long-distance trade in slave in
particular and through which the rulers
express power and so the idiom of power
is a link to Atlantic Network and is
linked to imported objects ok I'm
curious to know if you were able to find
any of the objects in Africa versus you
know the museum's of Europe so do they
still have some of the pieces there yes
absolutely
I'm at the stage of the research that
I'm going to spend a lot of time looking
at the European records first in terms
of the slave trading records and then
going to museums that have some of these
objects in Europe but also I want to go
into the factories some of them are
still Ian's activities in terms of
textile making in Europe to look at
their record and see you know what they
have in terms of that particular moment
in their activity and then once I have a
better understanding of what and how and
what it looked like the second part of
my research will be to go back to some
places on the African Atlantic coast and
conduct oral histories
when I know exactly what to ask and
about what type of objects and features
would be interesting to to know more and
I have been in some of the museum and
respiratory's some of them are linked to
still local rulers in around the mouth
of the Congo for example and some of
this trade objects are very much they're
still displayed as part of the regalia
of the rulers or part of the kind of
elite objects of a past that is not so
distant and so it would be really
interesting to look at that and some of
the objects also ends up being part of
Finnerty riyals that are decorating or I
should say more enhancing the tombs of
rulers sometimes the actual objects but
in other times these objects recast in
stone or more recently in cement that
they are remade in a more durable form
in a way to be on top of his tombs so
I'm really also looking forward to
conducting that part of the research
okay well we will look forward to seeing
more from you on this topic very
interesting thank you for being here
today thank you very much it was a great
conversation thank you for more
information about professor from--it and
her research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you